I'm a forty-year-old successful
functioning human being if I lost this
right now be like wha
[Music]
one thing that I'm we continue to want
to do is bring value in this daily be
strategy I guess it's an execution video
series no place is set let's go see what
prep let's do the pret is gonna make for
you I just flew from Chattanooga Harvard
and I had a quick meeting with the team
some people at my house Marcus
[Music]
then I figured that's why he's here yeah
yes hi how are you how are you yeah you
got it my man good to see you Monday hey
how are you thanks for having me yeah
this is very green hey good to see you
brother
how you been really well that's great to
see ya hey guys alright Smits this is
Tyler Babbitt yeah this is actually in
my phone he's other Tyler just my State
of the Union of CPG and retail
convergence over next 20 years
yeah and how to drive those results in
whatever shape or form yep yep and then
your same sorry I'm out of you how do
you market to the century that you're in
yeah and how much time do I have
you've been an hour awesome and I can do
as much what's the max QA I can do why
am I talking some I think I've been a
very serious I think it's interesting as
today's episode of both there was a lot
of CPG talk
that's consumer packaged goods my plan
is to build a private equity firm on the
back of my agency to take advantage of a
fact that every one of these companies
won't do it fast enough well right
nothing else to say so that's all I know
how to talk about is you know obviously
media's where I started and I'll weave
that in because that matters but direct
to consumer econ smarta fication of
items like that all place the punchline
is how are you gonna sell a bar or a
bottle of every one of those products
know how they sell today versus how they
sell ten years from now is an
interesting conversation more
importantly how they can sell today
differently than they're selling it
today this is not just a futuristic
thing these people in this room are the
they have the most black-and-white way
to prove our allied in a company yet
they're not getting the support no till
I have to fight for yeah I'm right we
can walk in right no seven or eight
years ago I just really decided that my
quickest route to the New York Jets and
I think the moral this story I'll go
into my version of it but what I want
you to get out of it is look if you want
something to happen you can't just
visualize that this isn't the secret
[ __ ] you need to actually have a plan of
how you're gonna get there and more
importantly the bigger your ambition is
the more patience you have to deploy
against it the more working after I put
against it it's just the way it is
obviously your talent is a variable
great you're gonna crush it and make in
six months do you that's fine just not
how I see it and so the audacious wants
and needs of buying at least from a
business standpoint a professional
football team even back then when I when
just worth a billion I knew this was
gonna be a five six seven billion dollar
execution and so even though I did great
in a wine business even though crush'
and had popped and I I was building the
garyvee thing like and even though I had
invested in Facebook Twitter and Tumblr
at that point I still had the
self-awareness even though everything
was showing me with my investing that I
could make a lot of money that way I
still had the self-awareness that for me
what I thought was gonna be my best
opportunity was to go and not start a
brand because there's a lot of that
right now
you guys know a lot of people that are
that are starting a cookie brand making
the new peanut butter making a new soap
that's just not me like I just don't
think that I'm going to an event invent
the maple syrup a honey that's gonna
become a huge business what I thought I
could do is write on that why didn't
yeah yeah the reason I didn't invent an
app is because it just I don't think
that that's my position like like I
don't get off on excited or dream about
the idea of starting an app a wine app I
mean people were throwing tens of
millions of dollars at me start a wine
app build the wine Facebook they used to
say back then
lovino has done extremely well great app
it's just not well I'm not an inventor
you know I'm a communicator I'm a
business builder and I think you know
the the idea of creating the next
Captain Crunch versus buying Captain
Crunch when the company that owned it
didn't manage it well and wanted to sell
it off there was just no no comparison I
was more excited about that evolution
look look at my career you know I I
jumped into my dad's business and
exploded it even the first two years ago
I started vaynermedia and even though I
got this clients and was a part of it
those first two years I was like yeah
it's even my kids like the first two
years you know like you know it's it's
just the way I'm wired and and so I just
became very in tune with myself of like
if I've got this big of a dream it's
gonna take a big play and I thought the
biggest play was go out buy you know
build an agency learn corporate America
at scale meet people eventually hire
them build teammates you know and and
really understand it I think there's
never ever enough work put into really
understanding the landscape I got a
taste [ __ ] and so I wanted to taste it
and and I was willing to burn my 30s
into my 40s on it I was willing to in
the prime of my career put in the work
have the humility to go and do client
service eat [ __ ] have clients do all
that I was willing to do that and now
I'm you know I'm further along I'm on
second third base of like this amazing
journey and and I just genuinely believe
my ability to buy a brand for 5 10 15 20
million dollars and then
and then build it for three forty years
and then flip it for three four five six
hundred is very real
the if understand how big business works
a lot of you are young and entrepreneurs
if I was to go and do that then eight
years from now I'll still be 48 there
will be billions of dollars of investors
asking me to do that again and letting
them make some of the money along the
way and so this my friends is the
television and the television is the
radio go read what happened to the
biggest brands in the world from 1957 to
1965 and go look at the biggest brands
being built during that era every time
there is an actual attention revolution
enormous money is made and enormous
money is lost I'm just gonna go now
anything else anything else I'm missing
so I have a three o'clock
yeah you guys are we gonna go in or are
we gonna sit here
yeah they public when we have five we
just need one or two seats right we've
been trying to make this work in the
schedule I I have to go to Helsinki in
like five minutes so there's a big
conference they do the one of the
biggest European digital conferences so
a lot of fancy-schmancy digital people
speaking and me and so I'll fly in talk
and come back I'll be back for Friday
morning I'm a 40 year old successful
functioning human being if I lost this
right now be like look this is it this
is it and this is world and and the one
thing we all trade on is attention
before you tell me how delicious your
beer is or how awesome that code is or
how great you are
you need my attention and too many
companies have got away from that very
simple thing that that sign above that
taxi is still priced like it's 15 years
ago yet that dudes looking at his phone
so right look what he's doing so that
guy right there having a cigarette 20
years ago would have saw that I mean
this is amazing look what we're doing he
would have saw that ad on that but he's
not and that's overpriced honey I'm
touching you do it where people you
don't get it
you just go to where it is and you
figured out how to bring people value
within it got it
I mean that's it I mean like what's that
guy doing I mean this is happening in
our face I mean what do you think he's
doing you're not selling to him on this
outdoor media you're not and yet outdoor
media is up 12% in costs in the last 10
years
why because media buying companies they
have their business to run to buy a
banner ad on a desktop computer
environment below the fold on a website
that you don't know is insane and even
so I'm gonna see it
yes you know I said you're not even a
lease engagement by the way and I'm dead
serious about this I would pay for
seeing it I don't need to click it I
would pay for singing they don't see it
sure so our media capabilities have
excuse me thank you
very nice go change Carmen Carmen nice
to meet you I never do this I never do
you look amazing
Cheers
I believe did you say thank you we eat
meat don't we get it you got it
bye bye when we start a toothpaste
company and our director consumer
business is doing 80 million dollars in
five years because last mile deliveries
there and all this gonna care and then
I'm gonna like [ __ ] we have to be direct
to consumer and they're gonna say okay
now we have to be direct to consumer but
the problem is Walmart and CVS and
Walgreens are gonna say you can't do
that because we make money on the sale
so they're gonna say ok well we're doing
this new toothpaste and Walmart and
Albertsons and Publix is gonna say no
way if you do that we're gonna eliminate
your poor brands from our store and
there should be a conflict and it's
gonna be a game of who blinks first
meanwhile our little startup continues
to grow that in the next 20 years is
gonna be why so many huge brands died
this is what always happens brands
turnover all the time nobody sat around
thinking Nike was vulnerable to Under
Armour like that's not what we think
until it happens and this is happening
very very very quickly because the punch
line is and this is the one that you
really need to date debate for yourself
you're living your life one way as a
human by the show of hands that you had
but then you put on your business jersey
and you have your business card and you
work as a brand and you're acting and
allocating dollars in a different way
you're eliminating the comments of many
of you in this room have said to me but
Gary my target demo isn't on these
platforms yet you are the target demo
and
or on these platforms and soar every
single person you know do not live in
the world do not go out like this is
happening this is happening at scale and
everybody is stunned and so listen
what's gonna happen is the real
punchline is the Dollar Shave Club is
what's gonna happen every company in
here J&J all of you you're gonna go and
do M&A you're gonna buy these things and
you're spending way too much money on
something that you had way more money
than and to begin with and all you
needed was a slate culture change you
can reach more people more targeted at a
lower cost than running a commercial for
30 seconds in between an event on
television and that's it Sunday Night
Football is six hundred seventy thousand
dollars in media to get a 30-second spot
that nobody watches so you know I think
what's gonna happen is you know
entrepreneurs are gonna continue to
build things they're either they're
either gonna sell to bigger companies or
because of the way democracy of
distribution of information and sales
will change they're gonna hold out
longer because the stakes are gonna be
higher or big companies are gonna spend
more money on brands like you guys that
pop and you know it's gonna be the same
old thing with a different version but
the opportunity has never been greater
this is it man I mean like this I mean
this is it like this is the most like
like I literally rather somebody right
now come up to me and punch me in the
face and steal my wallet but as long as
I have my phone right like like it's
crazy like all right I'll see you guys
later
yeah body wash yeah bye guys
which one this one
putting yourself in the best position to
succeed I know I can do it I know that I
can buy
Lucky Charms Peter Pan peanut butter
pace with sneakers fresh those tires
like like a brand that exists and make
it 2018-2019 now and explode
it's a top-line growth it's what I do
I'm great at seeing something already
understanding what it did to get there
and knowing exactly what they do to get
to the next place and I know how to do
that in marketing and more than anything
and marketing of a product is what comes
most natural to me it's what I do best
I'm good at speaking I'm gonna making
videos I can play a little bit pong you
know I'm good at stuff what a great
storytelling marketing understanding the
arbitrage in the white space in the
marketing world and selling [ __ ] and
this will be very satisfying to watch us
through and episode whatever this is one
day when I when I'm in execution mode in
that and so that's why I did it
that's what and that's why today's talks
important some may watch today's talk
you'll see a good chunk of it and you'll
say oh he did that that was smart he'll
get clients for that's true way more
important I'm weeding out the people
that agree and disagree with me about
where the world's going in the next ten
years and I'm building relationships
with the ones that agree with me because
they can become integral pieces and
parts of building this ultimate
[Music]
[Music]